so what have you showed up in a workshop
Ren walking in the wrong door and then
all the folks the surrealism entrances
being set up for crime he didn't commit
and be on the run it's funny
accidentally killed somebody or is
accused of accidentally killing somebody
he pick you because of that side by
tactical agents come charging after him
and he's got no choice but to fight back
well without killing them both chorus
world the accusation becomes true unless
there can let us know alien unless
they're a lesser aliens and that it's
okay yeah aliens the arm spell count you
can shoot an alien no repercussions
please soundly at night shooting aliens
calm best sleep I ever had just to go to
sleep because what I can to please I
think I my lives are going to shoot up
into the stars when I see that little
UFO crash in bright ma'am
price a bit it's okay we a lien
oscilloscope they got booties they got
booty I've been a good little worker bee
all day so that I could come back here
the last hour and work on some album
lyrics for the corridor you pee and
connect to the internet can connected to
I think the best Dimas I'm just
listening things yeah music video just
keeps going in him doing those things
now that it doesn't have internet 7s
with your ex's ordering food look
upwards and auto spell go to the bank
how many apps get on your phone right
yeah
dreaming music I used to hit pause on my
Spotify for track was getting loco and
also want to stop the Beatles got a
higher yoko damn nick seasons I brought
it back here put like a flesh flapping
fender phone I don't know I don't know
what I was expecting but this is a
football what's that frame shot supposed
to be just a guy getting shot in the
head
but I thought there is room for more
creativity in the shot
it just kind of oh my god dude that's so
Jack if you don't a whiz pauses on fire
when the track was getting local now I'm
kind of started because I'm I'm looking
for yoga pose porn II what do you what
would you do for porn without the
internet I would feel is elated then I
sell them to page going online and
pretending I made it now when I'm
feeling frisky things are much more
goofy driving by the corner and I'm
trying to get business there's good food
you can't rhymes on this style dog goes
to rhyme zone my style and it worked for
a while for a while now I got zero bars
and no producers to dial this is good
it's a start I don't know how to do
something in 3dsmax
that should be fairly basic worth it
there's actually simple fix that problem
you have to install blender and then
learn it and then
take the computer that 3dsmax is on and
throw it off a bridge do it again how to
known that person I chose to clone to
see this blender we're just choosing
comical time travel I can play guitar
for stay alive an equation like this or
subjects drinks ball you take a part by
piano ventral nerve cards against it
like what you actually play the song
let's borrow video right there listen
hey yeah let's do that
the ocean that next if you want to get a
hundred million views you have to do it
real if you wanted to get a million
views to do with the effects cool what
song you want to play you would go
looking for pretty be done and then oh
yeah only five only five chords or not
do you have a lot of people firing or
you're going to have a full yell for
guitars each set to each note not like
nerve this is actually a really good
idea we should do this something good
yes here's making music a new incredible
way so realistically exam then we weep
for people and we should have four
guitars just to be safe
what's happening all at once yeah no
cuts no cuts well I can subscribe to the
salmon eco channel right now and you
will never miss a video ever I try and
keep up with certain YouTube channels
just by going to their URL every once in
a while doesn't doesn't work very well
for me so subscribe and you won't miss a
single thing that goes on they want you
to nurse starts at my drums and make
beats why not just use drum sticks
because it's nerve or nothing just
kittens upstairs yeah I heard it really
skittish yeah maybe even likes Nagle and
like get a kinderman video I am
skeptical that we are even going to be
able to hold consistent beat here
[Music]
honestly just I think grown just a few
suck like blood splashed down so I can
angle it camera oriented right there
anyway to have the brains
keep rolling them like the hood of the
car a little bit throw like the motion
blur on there real quick sure everything
else looks super super for ya
do you think we can reminisce only using
blender
I don't know I'm curious to figure this
out a little bit not ready to completely
jump ship 3d yes the blender it's kind
of like I know what everything I need to
do is but I can't figure out how to do a
single one of these now or it's always
worth learning new programs because um
programs have limitations and your
imagination doesn't yeah you might have
made effective medicine oh [ __ ]
the thing I'm digging about Peters work
right now it's like someone's like
larger-scale he's encompassing so many
visual effects element ins with shots
you know I feel like Ren is kind of
being limited right now well like okay
for example in 3ds max Peter instantly
goes through the most advanced one it's
like it's kind of blowing my mind like
his shots are so much better than Ren's
now like he's beating around
consistently with like it
I don't know friend it's going to be
here much longer
[Music]